was it annoying to work with chris evans
who always seemed so prepared for
everything
he's right there
it was scary to me
hi elvira from geek culture in singapore
how are you both
oh very good
good
uh congratulations on the movie i'm very
excited for it to be out um chris my
first question is for you what was it
like when you found out that you'd be
voicing like the buzz lightyear and what
did you do to prepare for the role uh
yeah it was very exciting a little
nerve-wracking i went back and watched
all the toy story movies again and i
just watched all the pixar movies
because again they're they're so good at
uh weaving story together so seamlessly
it drifts between the more sentimental
emotional moments and the comedic
moments and
um honestly you can even listen to pixar
movies without looking at the screen and
just kind of listen to the life that the
voices have because
you think you're giving a very grounded
performance it feels flat you know you
you you have a lot more freedom to add
extra energy and extra beats and rhythms
to things that you wouldn't normally
think to do now chris you faced off josh
berlin and lost and arya facing james
what do you have against the rolands
seriously
we
beat uh josh berlin so
[Music]
which one of the two is more men insane
at the end
of one um yeah that's right you know
i've not met
james yeah um
he i'm sure he's a lovely man he's
wonderful in the movie he's got a great
voice um but
yeah
so on the other hand taika you have
called yourself a lazy actor in the past
so um
be honest with me how little did you
prepare for your role as well
there was supposed to be a comma between
those it was a list of things that i was
there
to describe me there were descriptors
lately
actor
[Laughter]
well it's only because like in my in my
films when i put myself in stuff i
usually leave the acting part kind of
that that becomes a lower priority
because i've got so many other things to
think about
and as a result i think sometimes
i'd wish that i'd been a little bit more
prepared like i'll spend years writing a
script and then i'll get to the day and
then actor taika didn't learn the lines
and then actor tiger is letting everyone
else down because he's trying to
remember the lines and then director
taika gets angry at actor taika because
he's wasting
hours of shooting time and the writer
taika hates everyone because he's like
why didn't you just learn the script
um
so that's why you know and so like i
felt like when when i don't have to do
those other things
i fall back in love with acting because
it's such a great
such a great thing to be able to do and
to just concentrate just on that then it
opens up and you can become
i find i've become more in love with it
was it annoying to work with chris evans
who always seemed so prepared for
everything
he's right there
was for it to me
um
no i love this men
and um
i was really happy when like yeah
when i when they asked me to do it as
soon as i'll be honest chris you haven't
heard this but like that my agent said
they sent a little thing and they said
but my eyes just scanned through the
thing and it was like buzz lightyear and
i was like yes and then i saw your name
and i just and i didn't read the rest of
the email i just went yes
but you know what we'll be seeing you in
space a lot you're mowing lightyear and
corgan for love and thunder
um what's your next space project going
to be about perhaps in a galaxy far far
away
perhaps
perhaps
perhaps
more than that
it's either going to be in a galaxy far
far away or in a neighborhood super
close to you
but you know uh lightyear buses best
friend is a fellow space ranger alicia
and in toy story it was woody chris if
you had to pick either alicia or woody
as your best friend who would it be and
why
good question um maybe woody just
because he's a talking toy and that that
would just keep me
i can't beat that right that's true all
right so this is my last question um if
you could film a childhood toy of yours
what would it be and why this is for the
both of you if i could film
do a whole ass film
a whole last one
um
[Music]
blue teddy blue ted my blue ted
he's a little blue ted that i rescued
from a trash can when i was uh four
years old and he's been with me ever
since not on the road now he's at my
mum's house but i'd do a film without
him i love that what about you chris
well i was big into ninja turtles but
they've done that already a couple times
um
yeah i don't know if i my childhood toys
were most little action figures and
they've all been done he-man gi joe
thunder cats ninja turtles
have they done a thundercats movie why
not not that i thought yeah why not
maybe you might voice a thundercat one
day
[Music]
hmm
[Music]